foreign
angels with us in Des Moines hi Angel
how are you
Hi how are you guys better than we
deserve what's up
um so um I love your plan by the way I I
don't have five Financial Peace
University but I have been following the
steps I started in September
um and I got my
um thousand dollar emergency fund and
I've actually been able to pay 25 000
off in the last eight months of debt way
to go that's awesome Angel yes yes um 10
000 of it was
um a gift my grandpa passed away and he
left each of his grandkids ten thousand
dollars and
I decided though even though it wasn't
fun and it wasn't something super
meaningful I decided to put just throw
all that at my debt and I knew my
grandpa my grandpa hated debt so he's
smart he's smiling then how can we help
today
um yeah so my uh my car is paid off I
drive a Acadia and we still have a
little bit of my husband's truck loan so
we only have one car payment
um I'm about ready to pay off my last
credit card and then we have a small
personal loan and the rest of my
husband's truck and unfortunately this
past Sunday we got caught in a hail
storm
and it really bangs up my car
um my windshield's cracked shattered and
tons of hail damage and so we've taken
it to the adjuster into insurance and
all that and we haven't actually heard
back yet but he wants me to get a new
car
who are you adjuster oh I'm sorry I
forgot to say my husband
my husband
my husband well you're gonna I have to
get another car probably aren't you
drivable okay but you think you think
the hails totaled it because it was
crappy anyway right
well it's not crappy it's a 2014 I mean
it's okay what's it worth
I'm honestly I'm not exactly sure I need
to find out before you start negotiating
with an adjuster right right I'm
thinking it's probably before the hail
damage was worth about 10 000. okay if
they total it then they're going to give
you a check for ten thousand why would
you need a loan it will
well because
this is the thing my husband my next car
he wants it to be like a Tahoe or you
know something we have three kids yeah
but you're broke and getting out of debt
where did he I thought so now I
understand why you said I paid off all
the debt I did this yeah I did that
because he's sitting on the sidelines
not involved in this plan
yes he's trying no he's not no he's not
he's a whiner
he just likes nice things no we all like
like nice things but only when I can
afford them that's the difference in a
child and a grown-up
yes yes and you've been defending him
for a long time haven't you
well and here's like I don't want to put
all the faults on him because I use I
mean I'm part of the reason we've been
in credit card debt like you're the only
reason you're getting out
that's the truth like I I put my foot
down in September I
love timber I turned remember that foot
you put down you remember that when you
remember that time when you put your
foot down yeah okay you need to use that
exact same motion again
we're not taking out a loan to get a
Tahoe yeah
and here's another one when you put your
foot down you and I are going to sit
down and get on the same page on money
I'm not gonna drag you I'm not your
mother
I need a man walking beside me not a
little boy who wants to buy things he
can't afford I've got to have some
teamwork going here I feel like I'm
dragging you around behind the car
yeah that's your other foot going down
and if you guys can't get on the same
page spend a little money on some
marriage counseling
yeah because here's my promise if you're
not on the same page here there are
other things in your house that you're
not on the same page for true or false
true true guaranteed
true yeah
so the the thing is is when you can
agree on your money you've agreed on
your life that's how John knows that
because your money always flows away
from your fears and towards your dreams
and so you have to agree on your dreams
and agree on your fears and agree on a
process that the principles of money
that are going to get us there the
principle and so you know the when we're
not in agreement on those things then
you know we're not in agreement on
hardly anything it comes it because the
money disagreement shows up in all the
other conversations
right so yeah listen your marriage is
gonna get like five million times better
when you guys are in agreement on what
you're doing with money because it's
gonna it's gonna filter into all these
other areas and I don't buy the argument
for one single second
that just because you have three kids
means you have to buy a land tank by the
way I love Tahoes I love them they're
incredible cars you cannot afford you
can't afford one well if you can find
one for ten thousand that's okay right
or if you want to be a gangster drive
your car that's drivable that looks
ridiculous and looks awful drive it
around yeah until you've paid off your
debts well this is what I
what I if you think it's a good an idea
but obviously I need a new windshield
but other than that the dents are just
like cosmetic I would like to take
whatever money we get from insurance
whether it's totaled or just
um whatever it needs to get fixed I want
to take after I buy a windshield I just
want to take that money and throw it at
our debt what how much debt have you got
left
um so like I I have two thousand dollars
left and with my snowballing I I will be
able to pay that two thousand dollar
credit card off this month okay not not
counting this okay how much other debt
have you got how much is
truck 15.
oh no no no that was what it was in
September truck is 12. and then
um our personal loan which this is this
has been years and years of us going
into debt and then getting out of debt
so this personal loan was through our
bank to help us pay off debt and we said
we never get how much credit card it's
12. okay so you got 12 on the truck 12
on that and you're getting 10. what's
your household income
household income I am self-employed I
I'm a I own a salon so mine what's your
household income
a month give or take his as consistent
mine is a little different so full stop
if you are if you two are actually on
the same page
you could drive this beat up car for
just a couple of few months
before Christmas you would be 100 debt
free
and then you would save up and buy a
better car before Christmas but you've
got to be on the same page for that to
occur and yeah you the your momentum the
speed at which you're doing this has
slowed down by your lack of agreement
I think so so oh I know so it's what I
do 100 percent yeah yeah so if you guys
can sit down and get on the same page
I'm with John I'd go gangster but if
you're gonna have to drag him down the
street with this thing I'm probably
going to go ahead and get a car because
it's going to take a while
but if you can go gangster for four
months and you guys get on beans and
rice you can with ten thousand dollars
towards your twenty four thousand
dollars worth of debt uh that only
leaves 14 you make eight a month we're
gonna knock that out really fast
yeah but you're gonna have to be on the
same page and say we're not going out to
eat and you have been we're not going on
vacation and he has one planned this
summer and so on and he can't buy you a
Tahoe at Christmas and think he's doing
you a favor with a loan right ever again
no more we're done
so yeah if you guys can get on the same
page that would be what we would do at
the Ramsey house but the the point being
all of this other stuff is going to fall
in line all this money stuff and all
this debt stuff and it's going to March
right down the street really really fast
once the two of you are on the same page
but you're pulling against each other
right now you're using all your energy
doing that and uh you really need to sit
down and do this so I'm going to give
you a Financial Peace University the
only thing that is required if I give it
to you for free is you have to make him
go through it with you
and I'll convince him because it's what
I've done for 10 million people this is
the Ramsay show